la vida vite tant attendu 38 pages dont
la moitié caviardé pour expliquer
pourquoi la résidence de l'ancien
président a été perquisitionné le 8 août
dernier d'emblée on parle d' enquêtes
criminelles déclenché le 9 février après
que l'équipe de donald trump est rendu
quinze boîtes de documents aux archives
nationales dans ces boîtes 184 document
unique dont 25 top secret avec
l'identité des agents de renseignement
qui travaillent pour le gouvernement
américain
il y à des informations dans ces boîtes
qui viennent de source humaine
c'est-à-dire d'espions dit il s'ils sont
identifiés dans des pays comme la russie
ou dans d'autres dictatures ils sont
emprisonnés et souvent exécutés
ce genre d'information est sensible en
tant qu'ancien agent de la cia ça me
fait froid dans le dos de voir que cette
information traîne dans un sous-sol
amara les choses les pages sont
caviardés pour protéger l'identité de
témoins ou d'agents du fbi et du
ministère de la justice
la perquisition du 8 août est justifiée
dans l'affidavit car selon les
enquêteurs d'autres documents contenant
des informations sur la défense
nationale était toujours amara lago dans
une pièce non sécurisés
quelle que soit la personne qui possède
ces documents de cet avocat si c'était à
mes clients ils auraient été arrêtés
emprisonnés
dans notre chambre fustige le document
parle de subterfuges total de relations
publiques par le fbi ou alors que selon
lui son équipe a collaboré avec le
ministère de la justice et puis il ya la
lettre de l'avocat de dornes chambre
adressée au chef du contre espionnage
dans cette lettre l'avocat écrit que
dans nos champs avaient déclassifié tous
les documents qu'il était dans son droit
et qu'il ne devrait pas faire face à des
sanctions criminelles dans notre chambre
c'est face à d'autres enquêtes dont
celle d'avoir tenté de renverser les
résultats des élections de 2020 c'est
assez peu de rigueur qui sera du canada
à washington